in the last video on exponential
functions we saw that
functions of the form y is equal to some
number to the x say y is equal to 3x was
what we used in the last video we saw
that these grow very very very quickly
so the shape of the graph that we got in
the last video looks something like this
it looked something like this gets very
close to zero slowly approaches away
from zero then bam starts to explode and
this of course is when x is equal to
zero so the y-intercept there is y is
equal to one but the important thing is
it just grows super fast but this was
the case where the base in the
exponential function is greater than one
you know here it's three if it's two
it'll still grow quickly if it was ten
it would grow even faster what i want to
talk a little bit about in this video
and really just introduce you to the
idea is the notion of an exponential
decay function so this is
an exponential growth
function an exponential decay function
has essentially as its base a number
less than one so an example of an
exponential decay function would be y is
equal to
one third
to the x power this would be exponential
exponential
decay and notice another way i could
write this 1 3 is the same thing as 3 to
the negative 1 so 3 to the negative 1 to
the x power i could also write this as 3
to the negative x power this and this
are equivalent and that's another
interesting way to think about
exponential decay functions it could
either be kind of a standard positive
exponent with a base that's less than
one or you could have a base larger than
one but you're going to have a negative
x as the exponent but let's plot this
just to get the general shape and the
shape will always be consistent i'm
going to do it for one third but it's
going to have a similar shape for one
half or for 1 10 or for 100 it'll just
be scaled up or down so let's plot a few
so let's have some x values and let's
have some y values
so let's say let's start with some small
values so let's say that x is equal to
negative three
well what is one third to the negative
three power that's the same one third to
the negative 3 that's the same thing as
3 to the third power which is equal to
81.
let's do another point what about
negative 2
1 3 to the negative 2 power is the same
thing as 1 over
sorry is it's equal to 1 over 1 3
squared which is the same thing as 3
squared you just take the inverse of the
number get rid of the negative and that
is equal to
equal to 9. oh i got this one wrong up
here
3 cubed isn't 81 that's 3 to the fourth
3 times 3 times 3 is 27
27 my brain is malfunctioning
what about when x is equal to negative 1
then you have 1 3 to the negative one
power one-third to the negative one
which is just three what about when x is
equal to
zero
when x is equal to zero remember
anything to the zero power is one
and then let's go to a couple of larger
numbers when x is equal to one what is y
one third to the one power is one third
let's do one more
when x is equal to two we have one third
squared which is 1
9. so let's plot this exponential decay
function right here
i want to draw it reasonably neatly
reasonably neatly and all of these
values once again are positive because
our base was positive
so
it looks like that
will start
so let me go
so let's say that this is
10
20
thirty
and let's start at negative three
negative two
negative one zero
one two
so when x was negative 3 y was 27 when x
was negative 3y was 27 it's right about
there
when x was negative 2 y was 9 which is
right about there
when x is negative 1 y is 3.
right about there x is zero y is one
x is one y is one third and so we
decline like this
we decline
let me draw a little bit neater than
that
these the k functions are harder for me
to draw
that's well let me do it one more maybe
i'll draw it this way
draw it in reverse order
now that's even worse one more shot i
think you get the general idea
that's my best shot right there so you
see an a decay function is kind of
reversed around the y axis we start from
a large quantity and we decay very very
very quickly so in either case
exponential functions whether we have
exponential growth or exponential decay
let me make sure that you understand
this growth applies to this thing up
here this is exponential decay that
either way when in exponential functions
things happen quickly
now use using what we know about
exponential decay functions let's do an
actional an actual actual word problem
so let me read it here it says a person
is infected by a bacterial infection
bacterial infection
and they say when he goes to the doctor
the population of bacteria is 2 million
so at the start
he's got 2 million little critters
two million
bacteria
two million bacteria the doctor
prescribes an antibiotic which kills
bacteria that reduces the bacteria to
one fourth of its population each day or
that reduces the bacteria population to
one-fourth of its size each day
so we have the antibiotic
anti-biotic
and it cuts down the population so if on
it cuts down i guess we could say
reduces
population
to
one-fourth of of i guess you could say
the previous population
previous population
each
day
so they ask us a couple of things draw
the graph of the size of the box of the
bacteria population against time in days
so let's draw this so day
and then
population
population
so let's say on day 0 before you went to
the doctor your population is going to
be two
million
now on day one what happens
on day one you've taken their antibiotic
right the antibiotic is starting right
there so it reduces it to one fourth of
your previous population so now your
population is going to be 1 4
times 2 million
which is equal to what 500
equal to 500 000. then on day 2 what
happens
on day 2 is going to be 1 one-fourth of
this it's going to be one-fourth of your
previous day one-fourth of one-fourth
of
your previo of that 2 million
of that 2 million so it's one-fourth of
this 500 000 which is one hundred and
twenty five thousand i think you're
starting to see the pattern that's
emerging on day three what's it going to
be it's going to be 1 4 times this thing
so it's going to be 1 4
times
this 1 4 times
one-fourth times one-fourth times two
million
which is essentially 125 000 divided by
four but the important thing is i want
you to see this pattern in general
in general the population at day n let
me write this in a new color
the population
the population
on
day
and is going to be equal to what it's
going to be equal to 1 4 to the n power
right this is day n on the third day it
was 1 4 to the third power times 2
million on day 2 is 1 4 to the second
power
on day 1 is 1 4 to the first power on
day zero there was actually one-fourth
to the zeroth power right that's one so
it's one-fourth
to the nth power
times our starting population times
2
million
times
2 million and if we were to graph it
if we were to graph it using at least
just the points that we have here
we're only going to be dealing with
positive x's
so on day 0 we start at 2 million
so let's let's say this is a million so
in day zero we're at two million on day
one
on day one we're one-fourth of that so
let's say that's one million
so then that is five hundred thousand on
day two where 1 4th of this
so this is 250 000 that's 125 000. and
then on day 3 we're one-fourth of that
so you see the population of our
bacteria really goes down very quickly
never gets quite to zero we're always
going to have some bacteria well
eventually you're gonna have one
bacteria and you're gonna get the
antibiotic and it's gonna have a
one-fourth chance of hitting it so maybe
eventually you'll get to zero but it
slowly gets to zero but the absolute
number decreases very
very fast now they also ask us find the
size of the bacteria population
10 days after the drug was first taken
so after
10 days
so that's just n is equal to 10 so it's
going to be equal to 1 4
to the 10th power times 2 million
and let's take our calculator out to
calculate this
so let's take
1 divided by 4
to the 10th power
to the 10th power
that's equal to this very small number
times 2 million 1 2 3
one two three
is equal to we're only going to have 1.9
bacteria after the 10th day
so we're going to have this is going to
be equal to
1.9 bacteria so pretty much most of the
bacteria is gone after the 10th or by
the 10th day